you wanted to make films and I think a
lot of people want to be famous and they
just see YouTube as the way to get Fame
so they're chasing whatever brings them
Fame and that might be sensationalism
that might be throwing a car in a river
it might be whatever but the thing that
you would probably be most self-critical
about wouldn't be a lack of success it
would be being a hack filmmaker yeah
yeah I wrote a video this morning called
um I'm not sure if I can make it if I
talk about it I'll talk about it anyways
it's called YouTube makes me sad
and it's because I I'd like to think and
this could be my naivety speaking but
like I like to think that like the
driving desire to be on YouTube for for
aspiring creators is that they want an
outlet for Creative expression yeah they
want to make art and they want to make
interesting things they want to tell
stories they want to do all that and
when when I know that's that's my soul
driving force so I never look at metrics
I never pay attention if I didn't
monetize my channel like it's why I
never focused on any of that [__] I just
wanted to make things that were I
thought was good yeah and now I think
the pendulum has swung so far in the
other direction yeah
um where it's just about like
monetization I remember was that like
this YouTube conference thing a year a
year and a half ago and like the guy I
was interviewing me was like so
the first person you should hire when
you are are getting big as an editor
what do you think the second person you
should hire us and I'm like who the [__]
says you should hire an editor I was
like I've never worked with an editor I
was like the edit is where I write the
story the editors and he's like you know
the the assumption that he was making
yeah is that like the purpose of this
solely is to grow yeah not to make
something that is about creativity and I
reject that so so like wholeheartedly so
handily I [__] hate that yeah and I
think that that is what sort of YouTube
culture has become yeah
um and it's a bummer and I like to think
that like back in the Vlog days you know
six seven years ago it was much more
about creativity and now it's much more
about metrics numbers like [__]
juking the algorithm yeah maximizing
retention I don't give a [__] about any
of that yeah I don't that's why my
brother Van Nuys that's my favorite
YouTuber he literally doesn't look at
that his wife uploads his videos he
finishes them and then and then starts
making another one yeah he doesn't even
look at his back he doesn't have access
to his back he doesn't give a [__] yeah
he just makes what he's creation for
creation that's exactly right and I
think there's that's the most beautiful
thing yeah how long did you go before
you decided to monetize and what I want
to be clear here I [__] regret it and
it was stupid if I could go back in time
I would have push that button on these
good too yeah yeah but um 100 million
views before I turned on monetization
and I didn't know how to do it my reason
was like I spoke at a YouTube panel
about it when I slide not turned on
monetization and it was like the reason
why is I felt like one this was back
when not all videos had ads and like
when a video would have an ad I'd like
Ugh and sometimes I'd click away yeah
and I'd like to alienate my audience and
then two for me I like I made money as
directing TV commercials then yeah like
doing other work so I wanted to think of
YouTube purely as just like an outlet
for passion projects and the minute it
started making me money it would stop
being that I want to be clear both of
those things were grossly misguided and
I [__] regret it and it was a mistake
I should have clicked that [__]
button you know how much dollars 100
million views is yeah yeah could have
bought another car to [__] crash I
did the same thing
like when I started uploading I didn't
put the ad because I was worried that
people would click away because I would
always click away
and then I didn't realize until much
later on that like YouTube wants there
to be ads you get more views yeah they
if they're making money
right then they might show your [__] to
more people yeah
[Applause]
money is good how much is Logan paying
you bro zero this is I'm bringing this
up because this is something I'm
embarrassed about and I needed someone
to talk to about it and I thought this
would be an appropriate event you love
Prime energy
Logan's a friend I love the guy yes and
he told me about prime before he
launched it yeah and I don't know if
it's him or just the smart people
running his company but cases of this
[__] shows up in my office yes
and I have like an unbelievable
addiction to it have you tried this [__]
we have he sends us cases to our old
office and I just haven't correcting her
yet
they literally DM me once a month ago
can we send you that Prime I go
absolutely yeah so it's just sitting in
some Hasidic Jewish guys like apartment
in Williamsburg somewhere there's an
artist in Bushwick that's just primed
out every day I don't know what kind of
[__] fentanyl [__] they put in there
but my God good stuff I try not to drink
more than three a day there's like nine
cups of coffee worth of caffeine in that
gets you going yeah he's definitely not
getting paid for that
[Applause]
because it looks like in the next year
or two you're going to see YouTubers
monetize their fan base in a different
way not through dads but through
products you know Jimmy's obviously
doing it with the feastables and the
cookies and uh Logan and KSI are doing
this do you ever wish that you had a
product that you sold yeah
um the other thing that I wish I had
done sooner was merch I always thought
merch was sort of a lame sellout sort of
thing yeah and I think I'm wrong about
that like I did do merch and it was very
successful and I think back when I was
like a kid and like I got a Red Hot
Chili Peppers t-shirt I wore that thing
every I just was so psyched to show the
world that like this is who I like yeah
there's something valid about that with
merch I think there's like a growth side
of it too when you're like
sort of predatorily if that's a word
like focusing on young kids tell your
parents to buy you this [__] like that's
bad yeah but I think there's a medium
there where you can sell something and
people are excited to support you and
you're giving them something of an
equity so I've done nothing against it
um I just have a tough time getting
excited about it getting excited about
yeah like I see Logan with Prime and
like that's the thing you literally
jumping off the top rope at WrestleMania
with a prime in his hand and it's like
brilliant and I
genius and it's awesome and it's the
greatest marketing coup in the history
of sports beverages yeah I
I can't do it and the product's good but
like there's
in my existence to like a a drink or a
something like I just like reading
videos that's that's the tricky thing
it's like all of your art has to be
centered around promoting this one thing
to me I just would feel inauthentic
don't get me wrong I love the idea of
having a billion dollar exit on a drink
I'll take the exit is it worth every
single video that I do I'm walking
around the bottle I'm on stage I'm
drinking it every joke is centered
around Prime I mean I will say like my
my technology company beam was very much
so I think a parallel to that it was
just a piece of software instead of a
sports drink or a t-shirt